schönen guten abend
die heute schon meine damen und herren
und wir kennen uns so gut nach all den
jahren ich kann sie nicht lange an lügen
der jubel eben war nur für mein ego ja
das hier ist die realität
haha hoffentlich sitzt da ganz bald
wieder frisch gebürstetes zweig publikum
aktuell heißt es alle kontakte
runterfahren in deutschland dem corona
hotspot des planeten ja die ganze welt
fragt sich was bei uns los ist wie uns
übrigens auch aber wer weiß vielleicht
bringen die gestern beschlossenen
maßnahmen der bund länder runde doch
noch die wende zuletzt hatte man ja eher
das gefühl advent advent die ampel pence
jetzt mussten sie ihr
infektionsschutzgesetz schon zum zweiten
mal nachbessern ohne in der zeit wurde
verplempert viel zu viel zeit aber am
ende war sogar der alte grantler
winfried kretschmann fast zufrieden wir
haben ja jetzt ein
ganz frisches urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts
dieses urteil ist
wirklich sehr wichtig und
suchen einen moment bitte
nicht
macht nichts gekommen ich sagte kurz vor
karlsruhe urteilt die letzte bundes
notbremse war nicht verfassungswidrig
wichtiger ist aber was gestern
angeschoben wurde in der erwähnten runde
flächendeckend zweig im einzelhandel
kontakt beschränkungen für ungeimpfte
wer immer das kontrollieren soll und
ganz viel impfen das ist das wichtigste
impfen bis die nadel qualmt leute ja bis
weihnachten sollen 30 millionen deutsche
gefixt werden höchste zeit denn drei
viertel der kliniken verschieben schon
planbare operationen jeder tag zählt
anstehen beim kinderarzt in
hohenschönhausen alle warten auf den
mann der sich der stecker von
lichtenberg nennt
bester porno titel aller zeiten der
stecher von lichtenberg guter mann und
jetzt kommt also vielleicht doch die
allgemeine impfpflicht trotz all der
sinnlosen politiker schwere warum kommt
die weil man statt rechtzeitig zweig
einzuführen viel zu lange rücksicht
genommen hat auf impfgegner und ihre
zusammen gegoogelt wahnvorstellung viel
zu lange etwas mehr aufmerksamkeit für
den frust der geimpften mehrheit wer mal
schön fürs nächste mal sachsen als
unabhängiger staat hätte überlegen sich
das mal zusammen mit der slowakei und
tschechien die höchste instanz der welt
sachsen dank absurd niedrige impfquote
schneeberg in sachsen kommen gestern
abend 300 menschen auf dem marktplatz
zusammen auch verkaufsstände öffnen
dabei gilt hier ein totaler lockdown die
inzidenz liegt bei über 2000 bei denen
die dort auf die straße gehen frage ich
mich persönlich wie es sein kann dass
sachsen in den pisa tests immer so
positiv abschneidet und dann der spitze
der deutschen bundesländer stehen
berechtigte frage habe ich mich auch
schon gefragt wahrscheinlich wird das
erzgebirge wald umbenannt in insidious
gebirge wenn es so weitergeht
gleichzeitig fliegt ein airbus der
bundeswehr corona patienten aus sachsen
nach norddeutschland und experten waren
die krise in den kliniken könnte
pünktlich zu weihnachten ihren peak
erreichen ausgerechnet würde man kann
den ernst unsere beschissenen lage im
moment gar nicht dramatisch genug
schildern
vorletzte woche haben wir gesagt es ist
fünf nach zwölf
letzte woche haben wir gesagt es ist
zehn nach zwölf es ist mittlerweile halb
eins was wann ist das denn passieren
dann müssen wir ja noch schneller impfen
müssen wir wirklich impfen demnächst und
zwar endlich auch mit hilfe von
apothekern
zahnärzten fleischereifachverkäuferin
ne quatsch aber mit tierärzten wirklich
kein witz tierärzte impfen in
deutschland bald mit und ernsthaft warum
auch nicht so ein rüde richtig ja genau
starb er braucht man seine corona
impfung ein vorrichtungen konzert farina
und auch gleich casterin ja der super
ich hoffe dass wenigstens ein leckerli
gekriegt und jetzt kommt also auch noch
omikron die in afrika entdeckte mutante
ja möglicherweise schon wieder
ansteckender noch weiß das ja keiner da
wer tatsächlich mal weniger panik und
deutlich mehr geduld gefragt am letzten
wochenende gab es schon ebola vergleiche
das ist unverantwortlich und ja so böse
das klingt auf eine art sind sowohl die
alte als auch die neue bundesregierung
vielleicht sogar ein bisschen dankbar
für nikon und sagen sich die
unverbrauchte klaiber omikron mutante
kommst zum perfekten zeitpunkt und zwar
um davon abzulenken was wir in den
letzten monaten politisch so alles
verbockt und zugelassen haben ja und
wenn den leuten dann in der endlosen
schlange klar so dass absurderweise
schon wieder impfstoffmangel herrscht
und wir uns wegen omikron keinen kopf
machen müssen weil wir ja schon an delta
scheitern sagt der kommende kanzler
gesundheit ja immer klar es kann
natürlich sein dass omikron der nächste
game changer zum schlechten würde das
kann sein aber wie gesagt kümmern wir
uns doch erstmal um delta der reihe nach
für die krise zuständig ist übrigens ab
sofort ein krisenstab im kanzleramt
unter leitung von generalmajor karl
neuer chef des kommandos territoriale
aufgaben ist ein anerkannter
logistikexperte hier exklusive bilder
vom ersten arbeitstag breuer ist wie
jeden morgen ganz normal zum einsatzort
geflogen hat die abkürzung ins
kanzleramt genommen und dort direkt die
impfkampagne durch schiere willenskraft
auf vordermann gebracht
wenn klar eigentlich gibt es in berlin
schon seit februar 2020 einen corona
krisenstab aber jetzt haben wir noch ein
mit generalmajor und sollte man dem
sogar erlauben den deutschen
föderalismus mal für ein paar wochen
auszuhebeln könnte das durchaus was
werden mit ihm und seinem krisenstab ich
gehe sogar noch weiter wenn wir die
korona krise wirklich in den griff
kriegen wollen muss jede deutsche
familie einen eigenen bundeswehrsoldaten
kriegen
die leute es ist 337 frühstück gesetz
wird 700 verfluchter saufen sagt
tagesbefehl wer heute guckt 800
homeschooling wahnsinn seit feld wir
bereit unsere familie managt läuft
einfach alles besser er hat dieses
dominante maskuline was zum beispiel
meine man total wählt
ich hasse bruch nicht dort bruchrechnen
hast dich auch lern du kannst jetzt
entweder anfangen oder wir robben wieder
durch den garten und am stacheldraht und
plötzlich hat der leeren so spaß am
homeschooling weil sie eben
zwischendurch so viele praktische sachen
machen ok siehst du das süße
eichhörnchen auf dem ast bevor du
abdrückt denkt an den wind ausatmen und
[Musik]
selbst die hamsterkäufe für den nächsten
lokal sind so viel entspannter dürfte
ich vielleicht auch kurz als klopapier
versuchs doch mal
ich versuche seit tagen und booster
termin zu bekommen aber bei meinem arzt
dass immer besetzt
ich glaube wir haben er damit
ja weitermachen
ja und man weiß auch überhaupt nichts
über die langzeitfolgen also gerade bei
so gen impfstoffen du weißt nicht was
das mit unseren eierstöcken macht das
ist null erforscht ich kenne ihn noch
aus dem studium früher habe ich mir ist
klar bei klaglos angehört aber jetzt
haben wir ja den markt kommt man kann
jemanden link dazu schicken dann kriegst
du die zusammenhänge
mindestens eine halbe stunde ruhe
trink dich gar nicht an oder naja ich
trainiere hat will jetzt mal anfassen
bret harte
stefan wenn du aussiehst kannst mit dem
müll runterbringen melde dich doch mal
wir können ja freunde bleiben
versager
bundeswehr wir dienen deutschland
die haben gesagt ich soll meinen
lieblings witz erzählen was mache ich
gerne also kommen ein pferd chef base
und der papst in einer bar sagt der
barkeeper
ronny endlich den zwei takten heute
schon kanal also geht doch